welcome to the show in the last 24 hours
we've seen some real sort of down and
dirty talk about the pointless political
football that is this government
shutdown which continues I guess now
we're in today twelve or so I mean who's
even really keeping track at this point
remember if you've not been paying
attention and I envy you if you haven't
I wish I were you
Trump wants funding for this ineffective
and outrageously expensive border wall
with Mexico so we shut down the
government he said in a meeting with
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer in
December that he would be proud to shut
down the government if that's what it
takes to get money for this ridiculous
border wall that supposedly Mexico was
going to pay for Democrats to their
credit seemed to be holding steady that
they're just not going to give him any
money for this really dumb and expensive
overpriced border wall and President
Trump decided yesterday to bring in some
lawmakers to talk he met with
congressional leadership from the
Democratic and Republican sides
yesterday Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer actually asked Trump why can't
we open government while we figure out
border security funding and all of this
other stuff and Donald Trump couldn't or
wouldn't give a good answer
Schumer asked again Trump didn't give a
reasonable answer Schumer asked a third
time and eventually Donald Trump said I
would look foolish if he were to accept
Chuck Schumer's office and why is that
because it's just optics
it is you losing out because they are
playing politics this is not about
what's best for the American people it's
not about what's best for the country
it's just about portraying the border
wall as a solution to something that is
actually that to which it is not
actually a solution it's about creating
a crisis with Kirsten Nielsen and
everybody who's apoplectic about the
fact that this is an emergency
despite the reality that there are more
net outflows to Mexico than inflows from
Mexico and it's about appearing strong
Trump can't
after saying Mexico will pay for the
wall
and obviously them not paying for the
wall and then saying well then I'm gonna
build it myself and not being able to
get the money Trump can't now merely
because of optical reasons say alright
let's reopen it while I keep just
chatting with Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi about what to do he can't do it
and then from the President to the
Senate just as that Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell said yesterday
that the Senate is not even going to
consider any bills that Democrats vote
for in the house to reopen government
even if they are identical to bills that
Republicans in the Senate
previously at least appeared to be or
stated that they're okay with if five
billion dollars for a little piece of
trumps border wall isn't included quote
from Mitch McConnell the Senate will not
waste its time considering a democratic
bill which cannot pass this chamber and
which the president will not sign
Republicans are desperate to frame this
shut down this entire fiasco as the
fault of Democrats as ridiculous as it
is but unfortunately even though in a
December poll a plurality of Americans
said it's mostly Trump's fault when
Democrats take over the house which is
happening in minutes it may have already
happened depending on when you're
listening or watching to today's episode
when Democrats take over the house with
Democratic control of the house the
blame is going to start to shift in the
put in the in the minds of the public
towards Democrats Pat and that is what
is absolutely disturbing and disgusting
about this which is that even though
Trump said on live TV he would proudly
shut it down the blame will start to
move to Democrats and we know that how
because even in December almost a third
of Americans were already blaming
Democrats this is going to become a
problem
yeah and Democrats don't deserve the
blame because this started when
Republicans had control of the
presidency and the house and the Senate
as you mentioned Trump said that he
would take the mantle for the shutdown
when he had Schumer and Pelosi in the
Oval Office and of course Mexico was
supposed to pay for the wall so
Democrats I don't think deserve any
blame but as time goes on they will
start
to share some of it and there's sort of
a structural issue at play with
shutdowns in general as well and I
talked about this on the YouTube
livestream I did last night which is
that one side doesn't want government
doing stuff right like there's a
political movement there's a political
contingent in the US that wants
government doing as little as possible
so if government is shut down even
though most of government is still open
and it's really just this political
thing they don't even necessarily see it
as bad and we have this new Congress
sworn in today everybody continues
getting their salaries so what exactly
is shutdown well other stuff but that's
positive for many on the right who say I
want government doing as little as
possible last thing on this issue Trump
is now claiming that Mexico will be
paying for the wall through the trade
deal that he signed with them which is
one of the dumbest arguments politically
that I've ever heard but it will
probably convince some people and this
is sort of how Trump is framing it up
let's say the wall costs 25 billion in
total to build the trade deal with
Mexico Trump claims will shift our trade
relationship in such a way that even if
the wall cost 25 billion by virtue of
having signed this modified trade
agreement with Mexico we will come out
25 billion ahead so it's sort of as if
Mexico were paying for the wall which is
may be the dumbest political argument
not the most you know gloriously and
hilariously dumb but really on its
merits shifting trade deficits or
surpluses that doesn't provide cash for
things like border walls
it's an infantile and silly argument
based on a completely incorrect
understanding of how government works
but some of his followers are falling
for it and they're tweeting me about it
and it's going to work unfortunately
which is why Democrats need to take
control of this situation immediately
upon taking control of the House of
Representatives which is now as we're
filming and maybe a few hours ago by the
time you watch this